muito obrigada pelo convite
eu queria começar com uma história
antiga que conta que mestre e aprendiz
caminhavam por um povoado uma situação e
nos pita muito difícil de sobreviver e
aliviam uma casa muito pobre com uma
família de escassos recursos
o mestre pergunta pede o aprendiz que
pergunte aos moradores da família como
eles faziam para sobreviver
o homem responde bem nós temos uma
vaquinha e com o pouco que dá essa vaca
mas conseguimos sobreviver
o mestre sabendo da explicação perde
aquela noite que o aprendiz volte ao
povoado e atire a vaca no precipício
o aprendiz mesmo sem entender por que a
contragosto vai lá e faz
anos depois os dois regressam ao povoado
encontram uma casa diferente bem
estruturada com uma família bem vestida
para entendo viver muito bem o aprendiz
talvez com peso na consciência por ter
feito aquilo
pergunta aquela família e eu tive aqui
faz alguns anos e era uma casa diferente
vive uma família muito pobre
você sabe o que aconteceu ea resposta do
homem é aconteceu nada somos nós na
nossa história da nossa família
nós tínhamos uma vaca e num acidente ela
morreu e depois disso nós tivemos que
batalhar por outras alternativas e com
outros recursos entendendo melhor as
nossas capacidades nós melhoramos de
vida o amor ou da história que o setor é
muito apelativa para nós porque ela pede
que nós mantemos as nossas vacas e as
nossas vacas e qualquer situação
financeira ou pessoal que nos determina
e que nos atinge alguma situação rígida
é difícil de sair
quando a gente pensa em tomada de
decisão a gente pensa em liberdade a
gente pensa em poder ser que a gente
quiser em potencialidades
a gente gosta da idéia de livre arbítrio
ea gente não gosta da idéia de ser
determinado o que eu convido vocês a
pensar que como o neurocientista
estudando tomada de decisão são alguns
pressupostos que a gente tem sobre como
a gente toma a decisão
então eu queria questionar se sempre a
melhor alternativa é decidir se nós
temos controle sobre as nossas decisões
e se a gente tem como fazer para tomar
melhores decisões
então o primeiro pressuposto que eu
gostaria de discutir essas decisões são
universais
aqui todo mundo decide igual sempre se
você perguntar a uma pessoa
quantas decisões ela tomou ao longo de
um dia a média de pequenas decisões das
mais simples às mais complexas é de 70
só que algumas pessoas vão começar a
lista delas por exemplo com levantei da
cama
apaguei despertador outras pessoas vão
considerar esse tipo de atividade como
obrigação e não como escolha um estudo
cultural muito interessante sobre isso
vem da pesquisadora china e em braga
ela estava pesquisando participantes do
leste europeu ea gente sabe que nos
países do leste europeu há uma transição
cultural na oferta de produtos
as pessoas desses países não tinham
muita oferta do tipo de produtos
recentemente e agora passam a ter antes
do experimento dela ela oferecia numa
bandeja sete opções sete diferentes
marcas de refrigerante e eu fazia isso
sistematicamente até de um participante
disse bom mas não tem nenhuma escolha
aqui é tudo refrigerante
e ela escutando isso resolveu fazer um
experimento com essa bandeja
então às vezes ela adicionava água
às vezes ela adicionava suco e perguntar
para os participantes em quantas opções
você tem aqui e essas pessoas do leste
europeu diziam 3 refrigerante água e
suco percebam que a nossa capacidade de
distinguir as decisões está
correlacionado à nossa capacidade de
perceber essas minúncias essas
diferenças entre as opções e se por
alguma razão a nossa história de vida
não nos treinar pra perceber a diferença
entre essas opções acaba que a gente não
percebe essas decisões como decisões
pra nós sete marcas de refrigerante
são decisões e tem pessoas que brigam
por qual marca é melhor
7 então não há decisões não são
universais elas variam de pessoa para
pessoa de cultura para cultura
o seguinte preço por pressuposto é
quanto mais opções melhor
isso é um pouco paradoxal porque a gente
pensa que quanto mais informação a gente
tem mas munido a gente tem com relação
às nossas opções e melhor será a decisão
no final mas não é bem assim
é antes o leite vinha pelo leiteiro
essa é uma escolha simples não havia o
que decide hoje é o verdadeiro desafio
escolher leite na prateleira do
supermercado
isso é um exemplo de decisão simples e
cotidiana mas se a gente olhar a nossa
história de vida dos nossos antepassados
nem precisa fazer uma comparação
cultural dos nossos avós bisavós
eles tinham um papel social muito bem
definido
geralmente a mulher trabalhava em casa o
homem trabalhava fora às vezes da
profissão do homem era única ele era o
comerciante o sapateiro o pedreiro
e quando entrava em uma companhia
entrava e só sair dela quando for se
aposentar
vestir a camisa da empresa hoje a média
de empregos que uma pessoa tem ao longo
da vida é 15
por um lado você poderia argumentar bom
isso tem a ver com diversificação com a
sua capacidade de flexibilização de ser
plástico de inovar e ser criativo é um
ponto
por outro lado é uma área de opções como
você vai ficar satisfeito com a sua
profissão por exemplo sendo que há um
oceano de outras vocações que você
poderia ser
e se você está no trabalho existem
vários outros trabalhos o que você
poderia potencialmente ser mais feliz
a gente sabe hoje é que quando você tem
mais do que dez opções para escolher a
escolha fica mais lenta ea pessoa fica
menos satisfeita com a escolha dela
provavelmente pela perda de todas as
outras decisões que seriam possíveis
e você não escolheu o nome disso é
paradoxo da escolha nem sempre quanto
mais opções melhor o terceiro
pressuposto de que o homem é um animal
racional
todo mundo já ouviu isso que nós
decidimos racionalmente as situações e
situações mas a neurociência conta uma
história um pouco diferente
daniel kahneman é um pesquisador que
divide os sistemas é cerebrais em
basicamente dois um atrás do cérebro e
outro na frente do cérebro
o sistema de trás do cérebro é o sistema
mais inconsciente de decisões rápidas
daquelas decisões necessárias à sua
sobrevivência
essas regiões posteriores do cérebro são
compartilhadas com outros animais ou
seja na evolução faz muito tempo que
essas áreas são usadas em relação às
áreas responsáveis pelas decisões
mas corriqueiras mas importantes de
sobrevivência
geralmente a resposta desse tipo de
sistema é rápida
por exemplo se você quer comer esse bolo
de chocolate
a resposta é rápida você não tem que
pensar em parar pra pensar
o outro sistema de decisão mais frontal
se chama neocórtex e ele é mais recente
na evolução
são poucas as classes de animais que tem
e esse é o sistema deliberativo
responsável pelas decisões racionais
lineares em que você toma tempo pra
pensar talvez os dilemas mais moraes as
decisões mais difíceis recrutem mais
essas áreas frontais ea resposta é mais
lenta por exemplo a resposta para essa
pergunta não é tão rápido de responder
os pesquisadores é e não só a gente da
academia mas é gente da indústria sabe
da influência inconsciente nas nossas
decisões e por isso neuromarketing por
exemplo utiliza de vários apetrechos
para tentar inferir do estado corporal
da pessoa
as chances de ela dizer sim eu quero
comprar alguma coisa então aparelhos
como eletroencefalografia é airtrek em
condutância de pele e monitoração é
monitoramento decoração tudo isso são
ferramentas para inferir o teu estado
corporal quando você está colocado
frente a um produto e porque precisa de
tanta petrecho assim simplesmente porque
se você perguntar pra pessoa o que ela
quer ela não vai conseguir te dizer
porque muitas muita da da influência das
nossas decisões é inconsciente ea gente
não tem acesso consciente a elas
por isso que esses métodos fazem tanto
sucesso tá e por que é importante a
gente refletir sobre como decidimos
primeiro pra gente ter com
agência de que sim somos influenciáveis
e se escolher é uma coisa tão difícil
que às vezes gera aversão como a gente
viu quando a gente tem muitas escolhas
quando a gente sente muita perda pelas
escolhas que a gente não escolheu as
pessoas se aproveitam dessa dificuldade
e passam a nos influenciar ou a induzir
a nossa escolha
isso tem um lado positivo
quer dizer se escolher é tão aversivo a
gente aceita de bom grado quando os
sites como a amazon nos oferecem os
produtos que você gostaria também de
comprar se você comprou aquele ou com as
alternativas que o google de idade e
pesquisa
claro porque gera esforço ea gente gosta
que nos ajudem
mas é preciso saber que às vezes um
discurso de que é você quis
tem todo um trabalho por trás tem toda
uma engrenagem que está tentando avaliar
o que é que você quer e não é você o
autor dessa decisão
então precisa ter consciência de que nós
somos influenciáveis segundo porque a
gente não decide sozinho às vezes a
gente decide em grupo e às vezes a nossa
decisão impacta várias pessoas sobre
isso temos tudo muito interessante de
maria no sigma e dan ariely fizeram um
estudo sobre escolhas com milhares de
pessoas
eles pediram para que individualmente as
pessoas estimassem altura da torre
eiffel e quando acontece isso é quando
você pesquisa com milhares de pessoas
acontece um fenômeno muito interessante
chamado sabedoria das massas por mais
díspares que sejam as estimativas
quando você coloca a média de de várias
delas aumenta e se aproxima muito da
estimativa real da torre
então eles fizeram esse experimento com
milhares de pessoas e guardaram
resultado
depois eles pediram para essas mesmas
pessoas se reunir em grupos de cinco
e tentarem chegar a um consenso e com
isso elaborar uma nova resposta
o que é interessante do resultado das
estimativas de consenso é que depois do
consenso de cinco pessoas
as estimativas ficavam ainda mais
próximas da altura real da torre
o que esse experimento nos mostra que
talvez pra gente tomar boas decisões
coletivas você precisa de duas coisas
primeiro preservá a pluralidade de
opiniões
tem que ter diversidade segundo que você
tem que dar espaço para discussões e
estimativas e grupais
é claro que estima a altura de uma torre
pode não ser comparável por exemplo há
uma escolha moral ou uma escolha de
política pública mas em tempos como os
nossos em que a gente vê polaridade de
opiniões em que as pessoas é não tem
consenso e que a gente tem uma urgência
em as medidas de política talvez a
ciência tenha alguma ideias sobre como
melhor decidir em grupo
se eu fosse resumir o que que a
neurociência preconiza a como ajudar o
cérebro a tomar melhores decisões
eu diria primeiro de tudo o que a gente
precisa investir em quem tem os cérebros
mais plásticos e com maior potencial que
é a primeira infância
a gente tem várias frentes de ataque
para melhorar a saúde mental ou a
maneira como as pessoas decidem mas se a
gente for pensar em população
quem tem os cérebros menos rígidos que
tem maior capacidade de responder a
alguma política são as crianças são quem
tem é cérebro mais plástico então aqui
eu vou dar conselhos gerais mas a ideia
é ter como alvo essa população que a
população que a gente tem mais
capacidade de mudar
a primeira medida é nutrição tão básico
quanto isso
a gente sabe que o cérebro é um órgão do
corpo humano que mais consome glicose
cérebro que não tem nutrição não aprende
num processo da informação
um cérebro que recebe uma dieta
equilibrada é que se nutre bem tem
condições de decidir bem
o segundo fator é sono várias pesquisas
indicam o poder terapêutico inclusive do
sono
o sono é capaz de eliminar toxinas do
tecido cerebral e tem um estudo aqui
brasileiro do instituto do cérebro é
feito pelo grupo do ci dade ribeiro que
apontou que tira soneca durante o
período das aulas
ajuda no aprendizado essa essa seria uma
medida muito legal simples fácil de
fazer e com resultados palpáveis
privação de sono é uma coisa muito séria
para aprendizado e também para a tomada
de decisão
por fim eu queria discutir saúde mental
o brasil é muito bom em fazer campanhas
preventivas estão no carnaval a gente
tem a campanha de prevenção à aids
a gente tem a prevenção ao câncer de
mama a gente tem prevenção à dengue
mas eu nunca vi uma política de promoção
de saúde mental
o quão difícil é a gente entender o
impacto do stress nas nossas decisões
o que fazer se você alguma pessoa
conhecida tem uma crise de ansiedade ou
então como identificar patologias
mentais como procurar ajuda
o dia em que a gente foi bom em promover
saúde mental
a gente também vai promover melhores
decisões
por fim eu queria voltar um pouco a
história da vaca porque a história da
vaca não é uma história sob controle
é uma história sobre potencialidade
às vezes a gente está imerso no mundo
caótico em que eventos aleatórios
determina o rumo da nossa vida
a gente sente que não tem controle sobre
o próprio destino mas o poder da
reflexão tá em saber das suas
capacidades dos fatores que determinam
das suas possibilidades de sair das suas
funções e eu tenho a esperança de pensar
de forma mais ética e solidária
muito obrigado
[Música]